[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna back here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the latest chapter
of the my hero academia manga chapter
158 in which we got some potentially
massive clues about the true origin of
all quirks about Ares incredible power
overhauls ultimate plan and more I will
give you my thoughts on the chapter
itself and I will also talk about all
the things we learn in this chapter and
what these things might tell us about
some of the biggest unsolved mysteries
in the world of my hero academia here on
the channel we make regular chapter
reviews for the attack on Titan manga
and I know a lot of you guys enjoy it so
I decided to make chapter reviews and
discussions for two my hero academia
manga as well if you think that this is
a good idea and you'd like me to make
more in the coming weeks leave a like to
let me know and if you want to be
informed whenever I upload the latest
review be sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell these videos will
not be heavy on the editing because I
want to get them out to you guys as soon
as possible but I hope they will be
informative and generate some good
discussion down in the comments and of
course this should go without saying but
I'm gonna say it anyway
these are chapter reviews of the latest
chapters of the manga so of course they
will contain plenty of manga spoilers if
you are not caught up to the my hero
academia manga proceed with extreme
caution this chapter starts off by
telling us that one theory states that
the origin of all quirks was a virus
that might have been carried by mice and
then spread to humans because of this
theory overhaul has come to think of
quirks as a disease and he plans to
eradicate them using Ares power and in
addition to his germophobia overhaul
also knows that if he can take the
quirks of the pro heroes away from them
then suddenly the Yakuza
once again becomes a relevant criminal
organization since it was the pro heroes
who managed to
their influence so long ago Aires
incredible quark is to rewind the state
of the human body
so she can actually rewind a human body
and human genetics too before a quark
manifested essentially making the person
quark less overhaul sees the power of
Ares quark as a way to destroy the
entire hero society which is so
dependent on individuals with powerful
quirks all of this stresses to us how
important area is for the story why
overhaul conducted all those brutal
experiments on her and why it is so
crucial for deku and the others to
rescue her from overhauls control in
terms of the quark origin theory I have
always wondered where quirks actually
came from how and why they started
appearing in the first place so I am
glad that we are finally getting some
hints about this now this virus theory
may not be true of course but it is
interesting because it would make sense
to me for quirks to be the result of
some man-made virus or mutation
otherwise they would not all appear so
suddenly and be so different if we were
talking about natural evolution of human
beings then this would take millennia
and humans in the same geographical area
would evolve in roughly the same way not
in such diverse ways one thing that I
thought of while reading this chapter
and something I really find interesting
is that mezu the ua principle is the
only animal we know of that has a quirk
and although he has the physical
features of multiple animals some of his
features are clearly those of a mouse we
also know that he was mistreated by
humans at some point in his life and for
this reason when he is in combat he can
be very devious and he enjoys toying
with humans so I wonder what if nezam
was one of the mice with the virus who
was experimented on by humans perhaps
humans injected him and other mice with
a virus that they wanted to use to give
humans superhuman powers create super
soldiers for the military or something
like that but then this virus somehow
spread to the next generation of
humans from mice and this is the true
origin of quirks now of course we don't
know how old mezu is if he ages normally
then he would be too young to have been
around when quirks initially started
manifesting but if for some reason he
lives longer than the average human
due to sub mutation due to his quirk for
whatever reason he could potentially be
directly connected to the true origins
of quirks we know that all-4-one has
been able to live for many generations
so perhaps other creatures in my hero
academia including mezu may have been
around for a lot longer than we think as
well anyway this whole virus theory I
think is really interesting and it
sounds a lot like a theory video I made
about Titan powers in attack on Titan
possibly being the result of some
unknown super-powered virus as well and
I am definitely curious as to what you
guys think about all of this where do
you think quirks came from do you think
the true origin of quirks is going to
play an important part in the story
later on let me know down below at the
same time that we're getting all of
these interesting clues and info about
overhauls background in the chapter we
are also seeing the epic battle between
overhaul in his fused form and deku who
with the help of auntie's power is using
100% full cow to face overhaul we also
see that Thiru cue is trying to save the
injured sir night eye by evacuating him
from the scene and taking him to an
ambulance we learned that in the past
despite the Yakuza boss's instructions
to stay away from work altering drugs
overhaul decides to use Eddie's power
with the goal of ridding the world of
powerful heroes and trying to restore
the Yakuza's former place in society an
interesting thing that overhaul says in
this chapter is that he wants to make
money both from selling bullets that
erase quirks to criminals and from
selling a serum that reminds the damage
and restores lost works to the heroes
this would of course mean that the
Yakuza would be making money on all
sides which is a solid business plan but
the Yakuza boss
that using Eddie in this way is
unacceptable of course we know that
overhaul disobeys this instruction but I
find it very interesting that overhaul
mentioned a serum that can restore lost
quirks we don't know is this serum
already exists at this point but this
could be a big hint that a serum either
exists or will be developed in the
future which would mean that our boy
medial could still get his quirk back do
you think that media will be able to
restore his quirk with the help of this
serum let me know in the comments this
is a big question that I'm wondering of
course medial such a strong incredible
quirk we know what happened to him a few
chapters back so you have really really
interesting development right here I
also think that this scene right here
may be telling us in a subtle way that
overhaul actually used his quirk to put
the Yakuza boss out of commission so
that he could take over and implement
his plan without the bosses opposition
just look at overhauls hand here and the
bosses face this looks very suspicious
to me and I'm starting to think that
maybe the reason the boss fell ill is
that overhaul somehow used his quirk
deconstructed that reconstructed the
boss's body in some way that made him
sick and bedridden and he then took
advantage of this to implement his plan
and to use arey in a way that the boss
specifically forbade him to do back in
the present Deku continues his fierce
battle against overhaul with Aries
health even though we have to remember
that arey cannot control her quirk and
although she is currently effectively
rewinding Decker's body so that he can
use the 100% full cow without breaking
his bones the fact is that she can't
control it and this means that she could
also hurt Deku in the long run perhaps
even rewind him all the way back into
nothingness as she accidentally did with
her own father in the past at the end of
the chapter Erica asks her night.i if he
really saw that that who was going to
get killed and he replies that this is
the unchangeable future that ISA but of
course we know that dec who cannot die
since this is the story of how he became
the greatest hero so even if he dies
something will surely bring him back to
life we already know that overhauls
quark can
people back to life and Eddie could
potentially rewind the deku back to life
if he is at some point killed so I am
curious to see how they will handle this
whole concept of deco dying but not
really dying all in all I thought this
was another exciting chapter that gave
us epic battle action and some important
background information as well as that
potentially very important clue about
the origin of all quirks let me know
what you guys thought of this chapter
what are you most excited about for the
upcoming chapters and what do you think
is actually going to happen to Deku if
you want to see more my hero academia
chapter reviews like this be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if you
are new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
my next my hero academia video project
is to make a video above the you a
trader a lot of you guys requested for
me to make a video about my theories
about who the you a trader might be
however I was putting it off until I
actually gave it some real thought and
had a good coherent theory Bulls too
looked at some strongest theories that I
could find on the internet and come up
with some of my own so I am about ready
to put that all down on paper and make
that video so look for that this coming
week I'm definitely excited to make that
happen as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see us
bass Cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]